el aluminio metálico se puede reciclar a
partir de chatarra derritiendo el metal
para evaporar las impurezas calcula la
cantidad de calor que se necesita para
purificar un molde de aluminio
originalmente a 298 kelvin al derretir
el punto de fusión del aluminio es de
933 kelvin la capacidad calorífica molar
del aluminio es de 24 goles por mol
kelvin y el calor de fusión del aluminio
es de 10.7 kilo jules por mol ok
entonces necesitamos elevar la
temperatura de este molde aluminio de
298 kelvin a 933 kelvin y eso lo podemos
hacer con la capacidad calorífica molar
y después necesitamos agregarle el calor
de fusión necesario para derretir
entonces el calor necesario
el calor necesario para elevar la
temperatura
la temperatura cuántos grados
necesitamos elevar la temperatura de 298
a 933 bueno si elevamos dos grados
llegamos a 300 y necesitamos otros 600
33 entonces necesitamos elevar la
temperatura 635
y así llegamos al punto de fusión
entonces el calor necesario para elevar
la temperatura 635 kelvin bueno tenemos
un molde de aluminio 1.00 para indicar
que usamos tres cifras significativas un
molde aluminio por la capacidad
calorífica molar que es de 24 jules por
mol kelvin por 24 tools formol kelvin
bueno esta es la cantidad de calor
necesaria para elevar la temperatura 1°
kelvin pero ahora vamos a multiplicarlo
por lo que necesitamos que son 635
kelvin así los moles se cancelan con
moles kelvin se cancela con kelvin y nos
queda usemos la calculadora tenemos 24
por 635 y eso es igual a 15 mil 240
y vamos a ver aquí tenemos tres cifras
significativas acá tenemos todos y
nuevamente tres entonces vamos a
quedarnos con dos cifras significativas
vamos a redondear esto a 15000 jules
entonces necesitamos 15000 jules para
elevar la temperatura a 933 kelvin ok y
ahora vamos a agregar el calor que
necesitamos para derretir una vez que
nos encontramos una vez que nos
encontramos en el punto de fusión de
fusión
eso es igual a un molde un bol por el
calor de fusión que es 10.7 kilo jules
por mol
y esto es igual a 10.7 kilo jules o si
quieren escribirlo en giles esto es
igual a 10 mil setecientos giles
entonces el calor total el total es
igual a la suma de estos dos que serían
25 mil setecientos jules pero como sólo
estamos usando dos cifras significativas
podemos redondear lo a 26.000 tools o
también 26 kilos urss
ok finalmente vamos con el inciso p
inciso b la ecuación para el proceso
general de la extracción de aluminio del
óxido de aluminio se muestra a
continuación ok que es lo que requiere
menos energía reciclar el aluminio
existente o extraer el aluminio del
óxido de aluminio justifica tu respuesta
con un cálculo bueno esta es la reacción
y este es el calor que se necesita para
un molde reacción entonces si tenemos un
molde óxido de aluminio y aplicamos esta
cantidad de calor obtendremos dos moles
de aluminio y 1.5 moles de oxígeno
molecular entonces para extraer para
extraer un molde aluminio un molde de
aluminio
a partir de el óxido de aluminio
se necesitan ok si esta cantidad de
calor producirá dos moles entonces para
producir un mol sólo necesitamos la
mitad así que se necesitan mil 675 kilos
jules entre dos y eso es igual a vamos a
ver
1675 entre dos esto es igual a 830 y 7.5
entonces se necesitan 800 37.5 kilo
jules esa es la mitad de esto aquí
tenemos 4 cifras significativas y aquí
también y que es lo que requiere menos
energía reciclar el aluminio existente o
extraer lo bueno para reciclarlo para
reciclar un mol
1 mol se necesitan
ya lo calculamos 26 kilos jules 26 kilos
qué es menos energía mucha menos energía
menos energía